poor hillary can't let it go
miranda devine's a columnist for the new
york post and she joins us
does the country deserve that miranda do
we deserve a rematch of hillary clinton
and donald trump is this really a
possibility
well jesse i think it tells you more
about the state of the democratic party
than it does about poor america that
they're even considering hillary clinton
that she isn't just being laughed out of
school for for
popping her head up above the parapet
from so desperately and so obviously
having her hand up and saying pick me
pick me
you know the master class so called that
she gave the other day that people paid
20 a month to watch in which she read
her undelivered victory speech and then
cried at the end of it with no real
tears that was the number one that was
her begging the american people and
begging the democratic party to look at
her as the alternative to joe biden
because after all she is younger than
him she will only be 78
come 2024 so she'll be the same age you
know that that he is now or a little bit
younger and she's also a year younger
than donald trump and she's always
telling us she's been doing interviews
repeatedly saying that donald trump is
going to run again in 2024 that that is
an existential threat to democracy it's
going to be a nightmare and really the
subtext is that only hillary clinton who
was so narrowly cheated of victory
against donald trump in 2016 only she
can save america and that's her stick um
she won't stop at at she'll do it i mean
she till her last breath she wants to
vindicate herself and you know if
hillary clinton is going to get in
trump's going to get in because he knows
how to beat her he's got her number he
did it before he thinks he can do it
again but if trump is definitely running
then the democrats are going to say
biden you you can't step down you have
to run hillary clinton can't beat donald
trump you're the only one to beat donald
you beat him before you got to do it
again just beat him and then resign a
week later so you have like three big
names circling each other
bernie sanders must be
sitting there thinking like oh my god do
i have to get in
well but aspara thought for the younger
generation of democrats they don't have
a chance because these people you know
they're in
close to their eighties they face it
they're octogenarians and they just uh
clinging on to power for all it's worth
will not give any oxygen to anybody
who's younger
it's left the democratic party with a
dearth of leadership you look at the
republican side there's any number of
people that could step up yeah but on
the democrats who is there that is
actually palatable to the american
people and i don't think that biden
would beat donald trump again
polls are showing that's not true i
agree and too many people see who he
really is i totally agree aoc is
probably licking her chops
at this set up yeah and that that talk
about unpalatable
we're in for a uh
a five-car pileup in 2024 miranda devine
thank you so much